I'm shigeru me again I am professor of  linguistics and I also teach Japanese  history here at MIT this is my 26th year  my linguistics work is on syntax but  recently I've been looking at language  evolution in my history class I I do get  modern Japanese history something I  started with John dollar it's a very  eminent period surprise waiting  historian of modern Japan John and I  have done this incredible project  visualizing cultures which also led to  the MOOC the arocs MOOC that Harvard X  and MITx did together visualized in  Japan three years ago I split my  position between MIT and the University  of Tokyo and at the University of Tokyo  I'm the director of online education and  there either get MOOCs and also open  courseware